welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where they all float with the
release of a chapter - I thought I'd go
back and break down everything that you
need to know about the apparent way to
defeat Pennywise the clown once and for
all throughout this video I'll be
breaking down the ritual of tchard
including the main differences between
the book and movie and how to use it in
case you ever come face-to-face with a
killer clown there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't had a
chance to watch it chapter 2 yet and
don't want to know what happens then I
highly recommend that you turn off now
with that out the way I just want to
give a huge thank you for clicking this
video now let's get into my breakdown of
the ritual absurd the biggest question
in both the book and movie versions of
it is how do you actually defeat an
interdimensional immortal psychic being
made of pure light when all you have is
an inhaler and a shower cap simple the
ritual of tchard dumb down to its most
basic form the ritual of tchard is a
battle of wills that takes place between
the minds and hearts of the losers Club
and Pennywise in the film the ritual
itself dates back to an ancient Native
American tribe that initially inhabited
the land that would become to known
history the Native Americans believed
that it was an evil spirit or demon
similar to the Wendigo and that the only
way to get rid of it was to trap its
essence in a container depending on
which version you check out either Bell
or Mike discover this ritual and
according to the legend it's the only
way to defeat the creature in the
original source material the losers Club
performed the ritual as children and
later as adults in the first ritual the
group believed that silver would kill it
due to its prominence in horror movies
where it was often used to defeat
vampires and werewolves
however we later learn that because the
children believe that it was powerful
that it took on the powers after Bill
researches the creature he discovers
that the ritual originates from a
Himalayan tribe and during the ritual if
the creature you're performing it on
sticks out its tongue you must stick out
yours too and these will overlap and you
can bite into the creature and thus
enter its mind it's very sort of
metaphysical and is to do with a
connection that will be brought from
being locked I to I with the monster
though anyone who asks the french-kiss
Pennywise is asking for trouble
as a child enters Pennywise his mind and
meets a giant space turtle called
michurin which i promised to cover in
another video down the line but for now
let's just stick to this anyway mature
and vomited up our universe yes really
and bill lens that he must bite on the
tongue not with his teeth but with his
mind and this defeats Pennywise for the
first time in the book the group as
adults are able to perform the ritual
once more strengthened by their love and
friendship during which point Ritchie
bites the tongue instead in its mind
with Ben beside him and they are able to
crush the creatures heart whilst Eddy
distracts it on the outside which allows
them to overpower and kill it in the
book as the child's storyline and adults
play out at the same time we are able to
see why the first performance of the
ritual only delays Pennywise whilst the
other one succeeds in killing it once
and for all
it's clear that as the losers became
older and more successful that they too
grew in self belief and therefore were
able to vanquish it now where it differs
from the book is that in the film after
making their way to penny wises lair
located below the Neo bolt house Mike
along with the rest of the group perform
the ritual but it completely fails they
use tokens from their passer are
connected to happy memories and join
hands in a circle only to discover that
they simply aren't powerful enough to
defeat the creature after bursting their
bubble literally Mike reveals at the
previous time that the ritual was
performed by the Native Americans it too
did not work but he believed that it
would for them due to their connection
the losers clubs still end up beaten
Pennywise however this is through pure
belief even without the aid of the
ritual this is because they are no
longer afraid of the character and
believed that even with just words they
are stronger than it and can overpower
it whilst the ritual is seen as a
failure it still helps in some ways as
it allows them to know their belief is
strong enough to manipulate Pennywise to
revealing its true form and thus it's
possible to use willpower to end the
creature whilst I've seen some people
say that the losers club managed to
defeat Pennywise by making it feel like
it had no day for the prom it's actually
a lot more complex than that
Pennywise exists because of fear and it
beads on it this is why the creature
tends to attack people when they're
vulnerable we see this when Ben is
scared to enter the library basement
when stan has to walk past his father's
scary painting which
I still have no idea where that exists
when Adrian Mellon is drowning and when
the losers Club have just been attacked
by Henry Bowers therefore if there is no
fear Pennywise cannot be empowered and
thus it shrinks down to become almost
baby-like and the losers are able to
tear out its heart and crush it now none
of these guys are like Lloyd Christmas
in Dumb and Dumber but because they
believe that penny wise has a heart they
are able to do it if they weren't in its
lair and performed the ritual it would
probably flee similar to how we saw at
the end of the first film but as it has
nowhere to retreat to you they're
finally able to kill it and take the big
jump into the ravine to celebrate
finally getting rid of that killer Klown
so everyone next time you walk past the
sewer and see a clown standing there you
know what to do just wrap your tongue
around its tongue and stare into its eye
enter its mind and overpower it with
your will by calling it Ronald McDonald
or something yeah just make sure you
drop a like if I've saved your life best
of luck with that
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the ritual absurd and how
you'd fight a killer Klown if you came
face-to-face with one comment below and
let me know and if you enjoy this video
then please give it a thumbs up and make
sure you check out my breakdown of
everything you need to know about penny
wise which will be linked at the end I
go over the characters entire history
origins and more so it's definitely
worth checking out if you want something
to watch after this if you want to come
talk to me about movies TV shows games
and comic books then you can follow me
on twitter at definition YT it's the
best way to get in touch with me and
it's the perfect place to suggest new
videos and content so hopefully I see
you over there after this also just one
let you know that we're giving away a
free copy of John wick 3 and blu-ray and
all you have to do to be in with a
chance of winning is to like this video
make sure that you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on the
ritual absurd in the comments section
below the winner will be chosen tomorrow
on September the 10th and the blue arrow
be shipped out from then to a baguette
surprise so best of luck that everyone
who takes part a channel for people who
are mad into movies so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best
see you next time take care peace
[Music]